[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance it ultimately does not matter
whether the president does doesn't has
or hasn't fired the special counsel who
is investigating him obviously this is a
simplified overview the grinding wheels
of justice and truth would be better
served with robert muller on the job
rather than with his being just the
latest body on the pile of men Trump has
fired as they gather damning facts about
him but in a larger sense firing Mullen
actually speed Trump's demise because
whatever breathing room Trump might gain
from cashiering Muller and declaring the
investigation over and himself
vindicated it would be more than
counterbalanced by the degree to which
the headline Trump fires another
investigator would move the story of his
alleged corruption obstruction and
madness into the center of the American
view it is hard for you and I to really
grasp this we have fought this man and
fought what he meant and saw clearly
what he would do for more than one year
for some of us exactly two years but we
are not average Americans and I'm not
talking about our political viewpoints
I'm talking about our political
viewership if you will I have never seen
a study of just how much time the
average American spends thinking about
politics each day but I would suspect it
is a lot shorter than the shortest of
these commentaries for better or for
worse to the average American even to
the average American voter this just
isn't necessarily a priority in their
lives a president fires the US Attorney
in New York investigating his associates
business dealings how many million
Americans didn't know this happened the
president then fires the FBI director
investigating his campaign how many
million Americans don't know that
happened well far fewer a president then
tweets he's being investigated for
firing the FBI director then fires the
Special Counsel doing that investigating
how many million Americans won't know
this has happened far fewer still there
is a tipping point in everything in
American culture from reality TV
popularity to political scandal
it is almost
always a lot of people who did not know
about something suddenly finding out
about that something you can't really
establish a single tipping point in the
Watergate scandal but the Saturday night
massacre is probably the closest thing
on a Friday Richard Nixon said he would
refuse a court order to surrender his
White House tapes and he ordered the
special prosecutor to drop the Watergate
case on Saturday afternoon in a news
conference carried live on television
that prosecutor said he would continue
the investigation
anyway and would continue to challenge
the president in court later that same
day the president ordered the Attorney
General to fire the special prosecutor
for defying him the Attorney General
refused and resigned the Deputy Attorney
General refused and either resigned or
was fired it still isn't 100% clear
which Saturday night the third ranking
figure in the Justice Department the
Solicitor General finally fired that
prosecutor and all hell then broke loose
on the Friday before the Saturday night
massacre there had been 10 different
stories on the front page of the New
York Times from the Yom Kippur War to a
shootout in midtown Manhattan to Game
five of the 1973 World Series nothing
about Watergate by the Sunday after the
Saturday night massacre there was an
eight column three line headline about
Watergate and four separate front-page
stories including one just about
impeachment by the Monday after the
Saturday night massacre White House and
congressional and Senate offices were
flooded with telegrams the Watergate
scandal front of mind for millions of
Americans but in its 16th month still an
irrelevant shape on the horizon to most
of us suddenly became the only topic in
politics and just as quickly politics
became the only topic in America would
trump fires Muller unfold precisely that
way it's impossible to tell the world of
media is utterly changed since 1973 we
have a thousand more distractions now
than we did when Richard Nixon had fired
Archibald Cox we have another president
who will lie about anything but on why
Nixon the one we have now can do so
instantaneously via social media and his
true believers will happily reject the
insights of Rosenstein and Muller to
instead swear by the insights of diamond
and silk but to fire Muller is to tempt
a repetition of the Saturday night
massacre and the spread of public
awareness of the investigation that
might not destroy Trump but it cannot
possibly help him and just as
importantly it is to risk a repetition
of the aftermath of the massacre the
part very few people noticed or talked
about then or now within 12 days after
Nixon fired the special prosecutor the
pressure and the outcry had grown so
loud that Nixon had to hire another
special prosecutor the one who would
ultimately help force him from office
resist peace